والان مشاهدينا اليكم نشره اخبار ال
المصري اليوميه واللي فيها اليوم مسك
اخطار انه خلص من غير اي رسائل غير مباشره
خلاص تعب الرجال قرر يعني انا صراحه بالفم
المليان فماسك قال صراحه لموظفين تويتر
خلال اجتماع زوم انه قال لهم انا الامر
الناهي والكل في الكل وقول له من القرار
الاول والاخير في الشركه بيرجع له بس وحتى
المجلس الاستشاري اللي في الاول قال لنا
راح ينشروا اخر الشهر وياخذ قرارات قال
انه حتى هذا المجلس وهم مضطر يسمع كلامهم
وارائهم لانه مجلس استشاري بس لكن السلطه
المطلقه والقرارات كلها عنده مركزيه في
القرار 100 في 100% ههه
طيب هذه مكه كانت الرساله المباشره
الوحيده الماسك اليوم واللي قالها علنا
كده ومن دون لف وادور في مصر كمان نشر على
حسابه هذا الفيديو
اه
فازر
الفيديو
المقطع ببين مجموعه من تيشرتات تويتر
لكن المصطلح بيستخدم مؤخرا في تحديدا وصف
المغالاه في هذه الاراء والمبالغه فيها
لحد التطرف يعني كانه تطرف بس هذه المره
طيب ماسكه في اكثر من مره من قبل انتقد
ثقافه حتى مره فيروس ماسك صور للناس
الفيديو ونشروه وعلق عليها لقينا من جدها
دوله تيشرتات في احد مخازن تويتر وايموجي
بيضحك والفيديو الان جامع اكثر من 13
مليون مشاهده ماسك هنا كانه بيطلع دليل
وبيثبت كلامه اللي قالوا من قبل واكثر من
مره واتهم في تويتر بانه مو حايد ومتبني
طرف واحد في الاراء واللي هو يعني الطرف
الليبرالي او اليساري وحتى بيقول انه
اشترت تويتر على شان انه يخليه اكثر شمولا
وعرضا لكل الاراء واا وجهات النظر